One more thing about the Muslims online.
>> [clears throat]
>> Twitter is a it's a pit from hell and I
get sucked into it cuz I'm weak, guys.
If I give you the impression that I'm
holier than them, then forgive me. No,
I'm not.
I'm wicked, I'm carnal, I'm sinful. I
cry out to Jesus day and night to heal
me and save me and wash me.
Save me from my sinful I know, but
sometimes I get caught into it, but I
want you to see this.
Libiyano
did this right here. Let me see if I can
find them.
I don't want to even open up the comment
section.
I really don't.
Is this What's his handle?
Yeah, right here. Look.
Libiyano ended up in the hospital.
Libiyano ended up in the hospital
because
of an asthma attack
and
he felt like he was going to die. It
scared literally the hell out of him.
I find out he's only 22 years old.
>> [clears throat]
>> Because he's only 22 years old, he's in
that age
where he feels like he can't back down.
He has to bulldoze his opposition and
treat them harshly, disrespectfully. But
here you're going to see a Libiyano
that's scared cuz he's young.
And because he's afraid of his
vulnerability that his enemies will
rejoice over him.
PS, I know my enemies they love seeing
this. It's okay, you can take your small
victory. It's not about me, it's about
exalting Islam. Truth be known.
See?
You want me there?
So,
this is when reality kicks in.
When death comes knocking,
when death comes knocking at your door,
you know what you won't be focusing on?
You won't be focusing on your debates.
You won't be focusing on your victories.
You won't be focusing on
all the attention and fame.
You're going to be focusing on
whether
I'm going to
be forgiven,
acceptable to God, or whether
God is displeased with me and he's going
to destroy me with everlasting
destruction. That's when
all of this all of this
will
appear
for what it is, nothing.
Nothing.
All of this
will be
nothing when death comes knocking on
your door.
You want me to write everyone got it?
Nothing.
So,
I responded to this. I shared it, I
believe. Let me see.
I'm on my profile.
Yeah, it's successful here, guys. You
got to be careful.
Yeah, it's successful.
And I said, "This is when we can rise up
to the challenge." Look at this guy. I
don't know if you know this. This is an
Orthodox
Jew
taking a [__] at St. James Cathedral in
Jerusalem, [__] on the church.
Yep, see?
But nonetheless,
here's a 14-year-old boy being gunned
down by the IDF. But, nonetheless, I
don't want to get you upset.
This is the world we live in.
Let me just show you this.
I thought Apostolic Orthodoxy was
condemning me,
but it he was playing a video where
Lebiano was condemning me, wishing me I
would got sick and I died cuz I became
obese and fat, and I started looking
like Gerby again. But, Gerby, I lost 25
lbs.
All right, so take it easy. But, here's
what I said.
Here's what I said, okay?
Zack, where you been? I left you a voice
message, dude.
This is when we must put aside hatred
and truly ask the Lord Jesus to show his
love and mercy to folks like Lebiano,
since at the end of the day, they're all
his creatures created out of Christ's
love,
right?
For his glory.
Pray that Christ will reach out to him
and show him his mercy
and reveal who truly he is. Now, here,
I'm going to explain to you why.
Can I show you the difference?
You guys want to see the difference?
Here's the difference.
According to Paul, those who confess to
be Christian
are to be judged more strictly and
harshly
from those who are not.
Okay?
Their [clears throat] judgment is worse.
You want me there?
So, don't think I'm acting
inconsistently. No, I know you guys
think I do, and I'm not perfect, but I'm
more perfect than Vartan,
and definitely more perfect than
Zack. Here.
Verse 9.
1 Corinthians 5:9-13.
All right.
I wrote you in my letter. What did I say
earlier? That if you're going to be a
dog and you're going to be filthy, I'm
going to step in the dirt with you and
stuff you with your vomit?
I wrote you in my letter not to so
[clears throat]
associate with sexually immoral people
like adulterous prophet
or not use Jesus as a cloak to do
ministry
though you've confessed to a crime that
has legal ramifications and you're not
absolved
and this means you are disqualified for
ministry. I wrote you in my letter not
to associate with sexually immoral
people.
I did not at all mean with sexually
immoral people of this world. Do you see
the qualifier?
Okay.
Let me explain.
Okay, listen to this so we can get into
the topic.
Or with the greedy or swindlers or
idolaters, for then you would have to go
out of the world.
You see what he's saying?
He's saying I'm not talking about
unbelievers.
Everyone with me there? Listen.
Don't let the demons and dogs manifest.
Just cast them out and send them out of
here.
That's it. Do Proverbs 26:5.
He's saying the world
>> [clears throat]
>> do not acknowledge Christ and submit to
his lordship.
So
you cannot pass judgment on them
because they don't
accept your standard
submit to Christ
and acknowledge
his will over their lives.
So I can't go to someone who's not a
Christian
who doesn't care about Christianity
who doesn't acknowledge authority of the
Bible and say abortion is murder.
They'll laugh at me and they'll mock me.
Or having sex before marriage is
fornication. May God have mercy on all
of us.
They'll laugh at me.
He's saying I'm not talking about people
of the world.
Okay, listen.
You You listening here?
What's he talking about? But I'm writing
to you not to associate with any
so-called brother.
I'm talking about those who claim to be
Christian.
If he's a sexually immoral person or
greedy and or an adulterer or of a
reviler or a drunkard or a swindler, not
even teach with such a one.
Do you understand our difference?
Do you understand the difference?
Christians are to be judged more
strictly.
Called to a higher standard.
Non-Christians, no.
You can't
hold them accountable
cuz they don't acknowledge your faith,
your law, your authority, your Lord.
For what have I to do with judging
outsiders? See, I know you guys think
I'm acting inconsistently. No, I'm not.
I'm acting consistently.
I hold
Great Apostle Woodstik, an adulterous
prophet, to one standard cuz they claim
to be Christian
and Libiano others to a different
standard.
They don't claim to be Christian.
You understand?
Are you okay with me reminding you
about these truths cuz I want this
channel to be used of the Holy Spirit
and the Spirit teach me, convict me,
transform me so I'm not a hypocrite,
practice what I preach, and work through
me to bless you.
Rumble, you see that?
Walking with Christ.
King [clears throat] of the Forest Camp
Dirt.
He says it right there.
I'm not talking about unbelievers.
Who then, Paul?
Are you not to judge those who are
within the church?
But those who are outside, God will
judge. Remove the wicked man from among
yourselves. You understand the
difference now?
You cannot hold Libiano, Cora, Tamy,
atheist,
to the same standard
that you hold Christians to.
Okay?
Let me go sit down now in the kitchen.
You want me there?
Those who profess to be Christian, those
who acknowledge Jesus as Lord and as
authority,
you can then call them out. But now
it gets a little more complex. You mind
me if I break this down a little
further?
Why does it get a little more complex?
Even this is hard to apply. Let me
explain to you why.
I'm going to teach you for a few
minutes. You know how it is, we wait
about 20 minutes. Hope you don't mind.
All right.
So, well, pray for me, brother, that I
practice what I preach.
At the time of the apostles, you had one
church.
Because of that, when
one church excommunicated someone,
all churches excommunicated him.
Let me explain to you the complexity.
Because the churches were one,
started by the apostles and their
followers,
if one church
ostracized, condemned, excommunicated a
member, all churches condemned him. He
would not be welcome in any church.
We don't live in that world anymore.
We don't live in that world anymore
because of the fragmentation of
Christianity,
you can be condemned from one church and
run to another church, another
denomination, without any
accountability.
Right?
Moreover,
not everyone
has the right
to judge other Christians
because they don't have authority to do
so,
because they're self-appointed,
their churches are man-made,
and their interpretation of the Bible is
their private interpretation, not
binding on anyone except those who are
stupid enough to submit to their
authority. Do you see how complex it
gets?
You see the situation?
In other words,
when you have these Johnny-come-latelies
whose churches were started in the last
100 years or 50 years by self-appointed
men
who have no
connection, continuity with the apostles
and the bishops they appointed,
who gives a damn what they have to say?
Who cares about their interpretation?
Who cares about how they view you?
They have no authority. You see how
complex it gets, right?
So, we live at a time
where even to judge Christians is not
easy anymore.
In other words, do any of you care
what a member of another church says
about you?
In other words, let's say you're
Oriental Orthodox. Do you give a damn
what a Grape is what Steam has to say
about you? Do you give a damn what Jay
Dyer has to say about you? Do you give a
damn about what No, you don't. Cuz you
don't acknowledge their authority.
You with me there?
This is the
reality of the church, a reality that
breaks the heart of Christ, a reality
that angers our Lord, grieves the
spirit,
because the church is no longer one.
And because it's no longer one, even to
judge Christians has become hard.
So, all you can do is disassociate and
not acknowledge the person
and not suppr- support them.
See how hard it becomes?
So, there you go.
So, the whole point being
Christians who profess to be a brother.
Look what he said.
One more time, I did not at all mean
with the sexual moral people of this
world or with the greedy and swindlers
and idolaters.
For then you would have to go out of the
world. What he means is
if
you were to dissociate with all sinners,
then you would have to live in a cave.
You would have to live in a monastery.
You could no longer
interact with the world.
But you are the salt of the earth, the
light of the world. You have to shine in
the world. Christ is shining his light
through you to bring the people out of
the world. So you got to stay in the
world.
So I'm not talking about not associating
with the world.
As long as you're not contaminated by
the world,
corrupted [clears throat] by the world,
polluted by the world, you are the light
of the world. You are the salt of the
earth. You're going to let Christ shine
through you to destroy the darkness in
people and bring them into the church.
So I'm not talking about that.
I'm telling you
not to associate with any so-called
brother.
Meaning someone who claims to be of the
household of faith and is no longer of
the world. He is to be judged and
condemned severely.
See right there?
Do you understand it, right?
So I will be harsh with so-called
Christians. I'll go after them.
But when it comes to unbelievers, no.
They they
I will call them out if they threaten
people.
I will call them out if they insult
people's wives.
I will call them out if they dox people.
That's one thing. That's you can call
out. You can warn people about predators
or not Christian.
But
when
an enemy of the faith, who doesn't
acknowledge the faith,
is sick and dying,
if you really believe in God, and you
believe in hell,
that person, if he doesn't repent, is on
his way to hell,
right?
So, in the moment of weakness,
when that person
is on the brink of death, that's when
you cry out to Christ to shine his mercy
on that person, right?